اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده
ابرز ملفات اليوم وفي ملفات هذا المساء
تسليم ابو عجيل مسعود المتورط في هجوم لو
كربي
لسلطات الامريكيه يثير وجدلا كبير في
ليبيا فهل هو مختطف ام تم تسليمه ولماذا
تشير اصابع الاتهام الى حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه وهل يمكن ان تتسبب هذه الخطوه في
اعاده فتح ملف ثم غلقه قبل نحو الخمسه عشر
عاما في الملف الثاني ريشي سوناك رئيس
وزراء بريطانيا حفيد المهاجرين يتبنى
الاجراءات الاكثر صرامه ضد المهاجرين
والبدايات بتشريع قانون لمواجهه تدفق
اللاجئين من البانيا هل يفتح هذا تشرع
الجديد الباب لطريقه المختلفه في التعامل
مع اللاجئين وفي ملف نق الثالث حماس
جماهيري فرنسيون مغربي كبير بسبب مباراته
كاس العالم ولكن لماذا تتحول مثل هذه
المناسبات عاده من احتفالات الى اعمال شغب
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل تستمر موجه الغضب
داخل ليبيا بعد فتح قضيه القربي مجددا
وعودتها للواجهه بين ليبيا والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وذلك بعد احتجاز واشنطن
المواطن الليبيه مسعودا المتهم بتفجير
طائره الامريكيه عام
1988 رغم تعهد واشنطن بغلق ملف القضيه
وعدم ملاحقه المتهمين رئيس الحكومه
الليبيه المكلفه من البرلمان فتح باشا طلب
من السلطات الامريكيه ايضاحه كيفيه الوصول
مواطنه ضابط المخابرات اللي بيسابق ابو
عجينه مسعود الى واشنطن وموسوله امام
المحكمه بتهمه التورط في القضيه ونقل
التليفزيون الليبيه عن بشرا قوله ان يعجله
خطف خارج الاطار القانوني والقضائيه
وكان المجلس الاعلى للدوله حمله حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه برئاسه عبد الحميد دبي
المسؤوليه القانونيه والاخلاقيه حدث تسليم
ابو عشيله الى وعشره كما طالب البرلمان في
وقت سابقا هذا الاسبوع في خطاب وجهه
للنائب العام طلب بتحريك دعوه جنائيه ضد
كل الضالعين في خطف ابو عجله المشتبهي في
تصنيعه قنبله جرى استخدمها في تفجير
الطائره الامريكيه فوق بلده لوكربيما اسفر
عن مقتل 270 شخصا وقتها
يعني
سؤال سؤال عندكم
يعني احنا نعتقدوا انه تم خطبه طبعا هو
خارج هذا العطر الاطار القانوني والقضائي
والشرعي وهذا سامر يعني نرفضه ولا نعترف
به
طبعا احنا قدرنا كحكومه وزاره العدل امس
دائره بيان وطلبت الحكومه الامريكيه
بالافراج على المواطن ليبيا هذا
ناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من تونس
المحلل السياسي واللي به محمد شوبار اهلا
بك ومن طبرقه المستشار والاعلامي لرئاسه
مجلس النواب فتحي المريمي اهلا بكم
الكريمين واسمح لي ان ابدا معك يا استاذ
فتحي نتحدث عن ابو عجيله مسعود شخصيه عرفت
منذ قضيه او ملف
اقيل فيما بعد في 2008 بان هذا الملف تم
اغلاق ونتحدث عن عمليه ارهابيه ادت الى
مقتل
270 شخص
همم هناك عديد من الاسئله في الواقعه تطرح
ان كان هذا الملف سيعيد فتحه او سيعاد
فتحوا عفوا همم ما الاجراء الذي سيتم
الاستناد عليه فتحه الملف ولكن الاستفهام
الابرز هو همم من الذي سلم او كيف وصل
بالاحرى برجل مسعود الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هل تم تسليمه من الجهات الليبيه
هل قامت بذلك وحدات امريكيه بعلم السلطات
الليبيه كيف همم اصوله
مرحبا اهلا وسهلا بك سيدتي الكريمه
وبسيط شباره وباجل المشاهدين ومشاهدي
قناتكم المؤخره معك فتحي عبد الكريم
المريمي المستشار الاعلامي لرئاسه مجلس
النواب الليبي من مدينه طبربور فيما يخص
[موسيقى]
تسليم السيد
بوعجيله مسعود
لامريكا طبعا هذا جاء نتيجه اجراءات يعني
تقدر تقولي غير قانونيه وما فيهاش اي
ترتيبات صحيحه مع الدوله الليبيه يعني حتى
من قام به خطفه او القبض عليه في مدينه
ولا في بيتها والله في غيرها كانت من قبل
مليشه يعني ما هي شمال في الدوري الليبيه
قالت بان هناك همم وحدات مسلحه بملابس
مدنيه دخلت الى البيت وتسلمت همم معجنه
مسعود وفيما بعد لم يسمع عليه اي خبر الى
حين سمع وصوله الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذا ما قالته العائله
نحن دوله ذات سياده لدينا مؤسسات يعني
شرطيه ولدينا امن ولدينا قضاء ولدينا
حكومه وولدين وزاره عدل ولدينا وزاره
الداخليه من خلال يتم تناول مثل هذه
الموضوعات علما بان قضيه لقربي حسب كل
التقارير يعني همم القانونيه بانه تم
اقفال ملفها منذ عام 2008 ولكن حتى لو
هناك ثغره لاعاده فتح هذا الملف همم ربما
يعني هناك ثغرات قانونيه واشياء ربما يعني
يفتح الملف يفتح ولكن بطريقه قانونيه
واحترام لسياده الدوله همم من اجل حمايه
مواطنيه
على اسقاط جميع القضايا في شان الواقعه
وعدم قبول اي دعوه جديده امام المحاكم
الامريكيه سواء ضد الدوله الليبيه ضد
المؤسسات ليبيه يفضل افراد واضح لاتفاق
هذا الاتفاق على فكره مره بالكونجرس مر ب
همم جورج بوش الابن صدقوا عليه واا مرير
الى الامم المتحده خليني اسال في هذا
الاطار لان الموضوع كبير الموضوع مهم يعني
حتى هناك دعوات من الداخل الليبي لي
محاوله تقديم شكوى الى محكمه العدد
الدوليه وبالتالي استاذ محمد من يتحمل
مسؤوليه تسليم او وصول لا نعلم المصطلح
همم لاننا لا نعلم الطريقه التي تم وصول
ابو هشيله مسعود بها الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من المسؤول
في البدايه تحيه طيبه ليك ولضيفك الكريم
ولكل الساده المشاهدين طبعا السيد ابو
عجيله تم تسليمه بشكل رسمي من حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه
للاداره الامريكيه هذا تم بشكل رسمي وبشكل
قانوني
وهذا طبعا تم تصريح به حتى من قبل
الخارجيه الامريكي
نقطه نقطه لو سمحت رسمي مفهوم قانوني كيف
لانه هناك همم في داخل الليبي من يقولون
بانه القطار ليست قانونيه بالمره فكيف
قانوني لو توضح لنا هذه النقطه
قانوني باعتبار ان الحكومه الان التي
يتعامل معها المجتمع الدولي
طبعا صدر بها القانون او قرار من مجلس
الامن الدولي هي الحكومه الوحيده التي
يتعامل معها وهذا ما تحدثنا عليه في
الاطار القانوني
النقطه وهي الغايه في الاهميه
ولكن ليس قانوني لان القانون تجاوز الدوله
الليبيه الى الامم المتحده هناك مرسوم
صادق عليه الكونجرس تلقت الجهه الامريكيه
عشرات المليارات من الدولارات قدمها وقت
النظام القذافي حتى يتم اتفاق رسمي بين
الدولتين نتحدث اذا عن جانب تعتبره حضرتك
رسمه تفضل اكمل
نحن نعلم جيده بان هناك اتفاقيه تم
توقيعها بين الجانب الليبي والجانب
الامريكي في سنه 2008 تتعلق بقضيه لقربي
ما نتمناها اليوم ونحن نعلم جيدا بان يعني
مساله التحقيق بدا فتح من قبل النائب
العام وهو الجهه الوحيده التي يمكن ان
تحدد ما اذا كانت الامر قانوني او غير
قانوني
اعتقد ان مساله الان ال- كل هذه الضجه
التي حدثت لا تفيد اي شيء لا في المعنى او
المتهم ولا حتى في اسره المعني نحن ننصح
اسره المعني بان تقوم بتشكيل فريق من
المحامين او مكتب محاماه من اجل الدفاع عن
المتهم ونحن نعلم جيدا بان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه همم يعني بلد مؤسسات
ويحترم القانون
وبالتالي يعني اعتقد الماء
عند هذه النقطه يعني هذه النقطه مهمه سيد
محمد لا اسمح لي لانهما لا تتفضل به وهذه
الدعوه التي تقدمها الى العائله يجب ان
نتوقف عندها استاذ فتحي ضيف يقول بان ما
يحدث ضجه همم لا اسس لها لانه همم كل هذا
تفاصيل ولكن المهم ان تقوم عائله همم
المدعيه بوعجله مسعود ب همم توكيل محامين
القادرين محامين همم فهمت منها استاذ
محمود بانهم او محمد بانهم سيكونوا سيكون
خصمهم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يعني
هذا ما تتحدث به ما رايك سيد فتحي
نعم هو طبعا الذي حصل حصل يعني وصل في
النهايه ابو رجيله مسعود سواء بطريقه
قانونيه او قرنيه في كل الاحوال هو وصل
امريكا وانتسل امام
المحاكم
الامريكيه في واشنطن
وطلبه حتى طلبه انه لا يشرح اي تصريح كان
ولا يدلي باي اقوال كان عن اي اسئله كان
حتى يضع محامي وحتى همم يتقابل مع محاميه
ويحكي معه في تفاصيل هذه القضيه ولكن جاء
الحديث عن
القبض او خطفها واخذ السيد ابو عجيله
مسعود الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بهذه الطريقه لا لابد لنا وان نرفض ذلك
ونعل ذلك بانه اجراء خاطئ سواء من امريكا
ولا من حكومه السيد عبد الحميد منتهيه
الولايه بالنسبه لهنا همم من الشعب الليبي
من حق مؤسسات
المجتمع الليبي السياسيه والاجتماعيه همم
ان تنادي بان هذا التصرف تصرف مشين ويتم
استنكاره لان
عمل بصراحه يعتبر يعني همم فيه همم فيه
اعتداء على السياده الليبيه نحن في كل
الاحوال دوله ذات سياده ولها مؤسسات ولها
يتها ما بين الدول وبالتالي همم على الدول
بامريكا ولا غير امريكا ان تعترم السياده
ومن حقنا ان ننادي
بان هذا التصرف تصرف صحيح بالنسبه همم
هل همم هي عمليات خطف هل هي عمليات تسليم
ولكن مهما تكون هذه التفاصيل ما الذي
تريده سيد محمد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من ابو عشنا مسعود في هذا
التوقيت خاصه بعد همم مرور 34 سنه
عن العمليه الارهابيه وقيل وقتها بانه
متهم بتورطه في التحضير للقنبله التي ادت
الى تفسير الطائره وبعد 14 سنه او 15 سنه
من اتفاق الرسمي بين الدولتين باغلاق هذا
الملف تاتي اليوم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتتحدث عن فتح جديد لهذا الملف
همم
ماذا
طبعا الى حد هذه اللحظه الان الحديث في ما
يتعلق بمثله تش- يعني تسليم السيد ابو
عجيله بشكل رسمي من الحكومه الوحده
الوطنيه الى الاداره الامريكيه وامتثال
امام همم القضاء الامريكي هي مساله قضيه
الى حد هذه اللحظه ولكن اعتقد ان الامور
ستتضح جليا عندما بالفعل توجه الاتهامات
همم الى همم طبعا همم المعني اعتقد انه
الان من المفيد بشكل كبير هو مثلا يعني
وجود محامي او مكتب للمحامين يدافع عن
الاتهامات الموجهه
للسيد
من الجهه المفروض اللي تكون بهذا دور
اعتقد ان الاسره المعني وايضا
القضاء الليبي او مكتب من المحامين
الليبيين معنيين بمساله الدفاع عن مواطن
ليبيا الان توجه له اتهامات الى حد هذه
اللحظه لم تتضح بشكل كامل اعتقد ان الان
حتى ما يدور عن ان مساله تسليم السيد ابو
عجيل مسعود مرتبطه بمثل رفع ال- همم
التجميد عن الاموال الليبيه الموجوده الان
في امريكا هو امر يعني عارين على الصحه
يعني بشكل كبير جدا واعتقد ان هي اوهام
تطلقها حكومه الوحده الوطنيه لليبيين رفع
التجميد بالتاكيد نحن نعلم جيدا بان رفع
التجميد على الاموال الليبيه سيكون وسيتم
قريبا جدا ولكن لن يتم في ظل وجود هذه
الطبقه السياسيه الفاسده سواء كانت
الحكومه سواء كانت المجلسين او المجال
ثلاثه نحن نعلم جيدا بان قرار مجلس همم
الامن 26 56 واضح بشكل كبير جاءت الفقره
الرابعه الهدف هو الان تشكيل قياده جديده
همم ولا اعتقد ان المجتمع الدولي سيعطي
لهذه او سيممنح هذه المؤسسات الموجوده
حاليا في السلطه اي دور خلال المرحله
القادمه
همم لا يتعلق برفعه تجميد عن الاموال
الليبيه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او
كما قال البعض بان الموضوع يتعلق بمصالح
الداخل اللي تم تسليمه حتى يتم ترتيب بعض
الملفات ومن بينها الاموال المجمده خارج
ليا
لا نحن لو ااا
لو يعني لو لو لو لو لو لو
يعني بمعنى نحن نلتزم بما تم بما تم صدور
يعني من مجلس الامن ومن الامم المتحده
بشكل عام حول الاموال الليبيه الان
المجمده في عديد البنوك
الدوليه يعني في العالم لا علاقه لهذه
القضيه بهذه الاموال الليبيه يعني بعيده
كل البعد عن بعضها البعض لو يكون في
التزام باختصار
صحيح ولكن اذا سلمنا جدلا بانه هناك همم
اوصات ليبيه في الداخل هي التي قامت
بتسليم او على الاقل تسهيل اصول همم مسعود
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم ما
المصلحه في ذلك باختصار
لا هو مصلحتهم كشف الولايات المتحده على
اعتبار انها دوله عظمى نحن جميعا نحترم
هذه الدوله امريكا احنا نعترضوها هي سيده
العالم يعني في النهايه ولكن لابد التعامل
بطرق يعني
قانونيه سليمه تحترم سياده الدول بالنسبه
لحكومه السيد عبد الحميد الدبيبه تقدر
تقترب من الاداره الامريكيه لتطويل الاماد
متاحه في السلطه
العباسيه التي تقوم بها حتى عندما ارادت
القبض على السيد ابو عجيل مسعود قبضت
عليهم من خلال ميليشيا مسلحه خارجه عن
القانون هي التي قامت بالقبض عليه وخطفها
وتسليمه الى شيخه اخرى في مصراته ومنها
ذهب الى مالتهم المالطه الى امريكا همم
تسليمه همم جاء من اجل مصلحه لهذه الحكومه
من اجل البقاء اكثر في همم
متابعه هذا الموضوع
فصيله سنتابع كيف ستكون التداعيات
اواتشكركم جزيل الشكر من تونس المحلله
السياسيه بمحمد شوبار ومن طبرقه المستشار
الاعلامي لرئاسه مجلس النواب لبي فتحي
المريميه شكرا لكم